uh hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason and
this is our latest live stream
featuring myself Zach Weissmuller my
colleague at reason a video producer and
author and the one and only Chris Ruffo
uh the Manhattan Institute Affiliated
scholar researcher journalist and
activist Chris uh thanks for joining us
good to be with you sorry I I I got in
right under the wire thanks for your
patience that's no problem at all no
problem at all Zach good uh Zach are you
uh coming through loud and clear yep I I
think so okay so what we're going to
talk about today is uh Zach recently uh
released a video documentary about the
stop woke act and uh related Florida
laws that dictate or have the would have
the state dictate what is allowable or
unallowable speech at higher ed and in
certain types of corporate settings
we'll get into some complications of
that Chris you were instrumental in in
kind of coming up with this bill
um and we're going to run a short clip
right now
um that shows you next to Ron DeSantis
then we're going to ask you uh what you
were trying to accomplish with this bill
and from there we're going to have a
long wide-ranging conversation about
what's going on with trying to uh
control what's going on in the battle
over controlling what's being taught in
schools and in the culture in various
ways but Zach you want to run that clip
believe in education not indoctrination
[Applause]
and that's I guess my first question for
you Chris is what uh how did you choose
what to wear
when you are standing next to the
governor who is signing legislation
based on you know part of your work it's
like that you know do you rummage
through the Wardrobe or is it it's just
laundry day and you show up in a maroon
Blazer yeah you just show up yeah I I
think so I try not to worry too much
about it
um but uh you know to the to the point
of it I mean that was a great day it was
very exciting I had been actually at the
launch event uh when the governor
announced the stopwoke ACT uh he's got
an amazing team of policy makers and
coms professionals I got to spend a lot
of time with him flying down from
Tallahassee down to Central Florida
um and uh you know a truly amazing
accomplishment and I think that what's
fun about it as a intellectual as a
writer as a as a think tank scholar
you know you have an idea you run a
campaign and then at the end you're
celebrating with the governor and he
gives you the pen that he signed the
bill with
what do you hope
um you know quickly um sketch what the
stop woke act does and um you know why
is that a good thing why is it a
necessary thing yeah the stopwoke ACT is
really the culmination of a long
campaign on looking at critical race
Theory and public institutions and the
stop woke act followed I believe you
know 15 or 16 other states and really
went a step further it's a it's a much
Bolder a piece of legislation and it
basically says uh something very simple
it says teaching that one race is
inherently Superior to another uh
teaching that uh that that one should
feel a sense of shame or inferiority
because of your skin color and a whole
other set of kind of what are called
divisive Concepts
um are are not in line with the values
of the State of Florida not in line with
the legislators and the voters and the
taxpayers and we're not going to be
promoting those uh racist ideas uh
through public institutions you still
have a First Amendment right you can
publish a book you can stand on the
street corner you can go on
online you can say whatever you want but
we're not going to have taxpayers
subsidized the idea for example that one
race is inherently Superior to another
because uh just to be totally accurate
about it it's not just about publicly
funded universities the stopwoke ACT
also required or banned uh private
corporations from having certain
diversity seminars that had these
so-called uh divisive Concepts in them
so it does certainly you know take
things to the next level are you how do
you feel about that aspect of the law
Chris
well I I think it's I you know I I think
it's fairly simple is that uh there is a
whole host of speech and behavior that
is restricted by the Civil Rights Act of
1964. and presumably these would all
this would already be included in that I
I think for example that if a
corporation uh tells a member of One
racial group that he is uh inherently
inferior because of his ancestry I
personally think that that is a
violation of the Civil Rights Act in
1964. many State Attorneys General that
I've worked with in the past two years
agree and yet corporations were doing it
over and over and over so the the real
the design of that section of the law
which is unique to Florida is that
you're essentially strengthening and
elucidating and clarifying in
legislative text uh the principles of
the Civil Rights Act in 1964 and you're
applying them in a direct way to solve a
direct harm that is being done uh to
employees in the State of Florida and of
course other places I've reported on
this at length these are the kind of
kind of racial re-education programs
that we see in many corporations that
try to break people down on the basis of
race try to shame and humiliate people
because of their ancestry
simply says we're not going to do that
anymore okay so I mean your your broad
context for this is that the 1960 Source
1964 Civil Rights Act had effectively
already eroded many of the you know at
that point more conventional traditional
distinctions between public and private
activity so you're building off of that
to say we're going we're going to start
applying it to certain kinds of Dei
training that we see in private
companies can you can you give me an
example of like what's one of the
statements that corporations you know
was foisting on people to say okay you
you need to feel inferior because you
are white sure you know you can look at
my archive at City Journal or on my
website there's tons of stories that I
did on the Fortune 100 company but just
what what's you know what's the
paradigmatic example sure I would say
this so uh for example the uh Sandia
nuclear weapons laboratory which is a
private corporation that contracts with
the government uh to produce our nuclear
weapons uh took their white male
Executives on a three-day uh White meal
white male re-education program uh it
told them that all white men are racist
that told them that individualism and
hard work and and the rugged and the
rugged uh pursuit of Excellence is a
racist concept perpetuated by white
males it had them apologizing and
repeating statements denouncing their
white privilege their male privilege
their heterosexual privilege and by the
end of it they were writing letters of
apology to fictitious uh women and
people of color uh simply for the fact
of being white men and in Florida
in Florida in the in the State of
Florida that kind of activity would no
longer be permitted okay was it being
practiced though in Florida
uh no the nuclear weapons laboratory is
in uh is in New Mexico it's just an
example from different corporations but
look I mean we know in Disney I had
another story when Walt Disney Company
their anti quote unquote anti-racism
program I don't have the details again
you can look at the reporting but it was
probably one of the most horrific that
was being practiced in the State of
Florida and actually when I exposed it
the folks at Disney the executives were
so uh embarrassed by it because it was
so obviously racist and discriminatory
and and illegal in my view even prior to
the stop woke act uh that they actually
nuked the entire program from their
internal servers and so listen
corporations know that this stuff is
wrong they're bullied into it by Dei
consultants and the stop woke Act is
very simple it says look
if you're going to do business in our
state there are certain uh guard rails
that were established Again by the 1964
Civil Rights Act
um and we're simply codifying and
clarifying them and updating them to the
new challenges that we see so and so I
guess the question for you guys is
simple
if you are critics and and you are and
that's fine that's why I'm here it's fun
to debate but if you're critics of the
of the of the stop woke Act
would you also not be critics and and
seek the abolition of the 1964 Civil
Rights Act well that's I think that's a
that's a great way to kind of frame the
debate yeah and we'll we'll get to that
in just a second but one of the things
that's interesting is uh Zach you've
talked to one of the plaintiffs in
Florida who challenged the stop woke act
um because the corporate uh part of it
has been put on hold because a judge
ruled that it it was overreach let's
just listen to her and then we'll get to
that and Chris I agree I mean I think
it's a brilliant strategy
um you know both rhetorically and
legally to frame this in terms of the
1964 Civil Rights Act I think Zach and I
actually disagree a little bit on that
because I'm probably from a Libertarian
point of view I'm more comfortable with
certain aspects of public accommodations
legislation uh than Zach might be but
we'll talk about that in a second but
let's look at and act actual business
owner in Florida
diversity is good for business and Men
ERS are shown to be more
person her husband co-founded honey fund
a Clearwater florida-based company that
administers online cash wedding
Registries their plaintiffs in the case
against Florida arguing that the law
restricts their freedom to provide
diversity training seminars to their
employees what was in the trainings that
you believe might have run afoul of
those kinds of restrictions so one thing
that comes to mind is the idea of
privilege that white people or males
have privilege that non-white people or
females don't enjoy and I think that
um the the concept of that the idea of
that is not something for us to shy away
from understanding and actively trying
to mitigate in our business
so Chris I I would say that challenges
your assertion that you know
corporations are all just being forced
into this I mean Sarah is someone who
clearly thinks that this is valuable for
her company and agree or disagree with
that well I said that the Fortune 100
companies uh please tell me Sarah's
company is not a Fortune 100 right it's
maybe you know okay
the big corporations are the only ones
that are being bullied into this but
someone totally there's going to be
hyper Progressive people she's obviously
one of them you know recruited to do the
lawsuit that they want to do it you know
there's there's communist businesses
that share all power to you you can be a
communist business
I'm sorry can you say again I can't hear
you
go ahead oh yeah I was just saying it's
it's not really all power to you because
the State of Florida has said you cannot
conduct these kinds of seminars that you
find useful in your own company I mean
at what point do you say you know this
is State overreach
um in in this endeavor to you know
squash wokeness or whatever well again I
think I'd frame I put the question back
to you Zach um the Civil Rights Act of
1964. it might be prohibits this but
certainly prohibits other things we have
a long history more than a half century
conversation should all if you reject no
but hold on if you reject the legitimacy
of this bill which is your fine argument
there's a Libertarian principled
libertarian argument to make it do you
also reject the legitimacy of the Civil
Rights Act of 1964. yes or no it's a
simple question
well I would say that it should not be
we should not be expanding civil rights
law at this point if anything it should
be like we need to be moving towards
more freedom of Association and more uh
ability for people to set up companies
as as they see fit and run them the way
that they want to see so yeah I do think
it's you know whether you know the
original Act was constructed in the
right way you know that was a kind of
historical question and uh I think it
was necessary at the time but moving
forward I would say we want to be moving
away from more intrusive State
regulation of how people do business and
you know Florida is a place that has
attracted a lot of business and
investment and I think that the the more
that that they are uh start you know
implementing uh
a management strategy I guess basically
from the state house I think that that
that puts that kind of pro-business
environment in danger and that's not a
good thing that I want to see but you've
seen Florida since the passage of the
stop worldcast record business growth um
wait wait you can attribute anything is
this in the country
when did the softball pack pass this
stop will get past uh I I don't know the
exact date you're gonna have to I mean
you've seen uh business grow since the
since the judge struck down that part of
the software you can't really I mean
you're making an argument that somehow
this hurts the competitive business
environment of Florida there's there's
no evidence
the State of Florida has shown to
actually be the most business friendly
state in the country I I'd be curious to
answer my questions you kind of hedged
it a little bit you didn't quite give a
clear answer I I probably know why but
on the other side if there's a business
in the Florida Panhandle and they want
to train their employees uh that
actually you know uh everything went
wrong uh and and during the Civil War
and uh you know and and and and and you
know whites are the the superior race if
they wanted to train that I would oppose
that to me that should be illegal you
should not be able to completely it
should be illegal like that one race is
superior to another but you are saying
that you would like to just as this
woman would like to say that you know uh
whites have inherent racial guilt
um you would say actually well a kind of
white supremacist business should have
the the the the equal right to say that
no actually whites are are are are are
are are kind of inferiorating
yeah actually actually who who would
apologize to you know uh certainly no
libertarian with would say you know what
white supremacists should be banned what
what does that even mean white
supremacists they're just no no but
you're just saying you're the law says
that if you have a business and then you
teach this you make your employees sit
through a meeting where they have to
listen to this [ __ ] you know that is
illegal I assume then there are fines
Etc that go into all of you know in into
protecting uh you know uh into making
sure that kind of speech doesn't happen
this I mean you you're putting
everything into an extreme motion what
the woman was saying was I mean I I
don't know anything about her but like
she wasn't saying that whites are evil
you know and that you know I mean or
anything like that she wants to run a
business a certain way sure and I think
with the within the greatest latitude
possible that should be allowed you know
and and the state you don't you don't
want the state coming in and saying you
know what any more than you want to stay
coming in and dictating how you cook
your eggs or how you cook your meat feet
you know in a restaurant you don't want
them saying Oh and you you have to
phrase it this way or that way yeah yeah
I mean I think yeah
uh the elaborate kind of uh restrictions
and prohibitions and guidance for uh the
storage of food I mean you know the the
problem I think that I see with the
libertarian position is twofold one it's
that you know there's a lot of people
who say well you know well do you want
to repeal the Civil Rights Act everyone
gets uncomfortable they say no I don't
want to do that I just want I just want
history to stop in 1964. and what
Libertarians do is they mistake the
status quo uh for the kind of liberal
ideal so it's really a defense of the
status quo rather than a principled
defense of Liberty which takes you again
in in a direction that most people don't
want to go a kind of unlimited what do
you mean most people how many
corporations how many I mean how many
corporations now or how many businesses
are creating Dei uh you know
concentration camps or re-education
camps where the employees are like I
cannot [ __ ] take it I'm quitting oh
oh well first of all a hundred percent
of the Fortune 100 have adopted AI
programs uh I have what is the best way
what is the best way to uh what is the
best way to kind of minimize the
stupidity of those programs and I would
argue first and foremost because I mean
we're talking kind of in principal terms
here sure is not through law and not
through giving the government which is
going to be changing hands at various
points uh carte blanche to come in and
say you can talk this way you can't talk
this way I think it's what you you have
been doing which is exposing the
silliness and the stupidity and the
right act of exposing it is not going to
change Behavior because again the status
quo is not the the the the libertarian
should not defend the status quo as if
it were the kind of classical Liberty
the status quo is what businesses want
to do and employees want to put up with
and customers want a value I mean the
world is so different now than it was in
1964. that's one of the reasons why Zach
is saying you don't need to keep
expanding civil rights protections
because we're not living in in Florida
in 1964 you know part and this is true
throughout the South and many parts of
the north the federal civil rights act
were pushing back against local and
state ordinances that disallowed
businesses to act how they wanted to it
was a you know it wasn't you know a
government overreach against not
government overreach it was a clash of
values sure oh and and I think that it
was very much necessary and I think that
again the the the Civil Rights Act of
the time I think was a necessary remedy
to a real significant problem our
problem today of course is not as it's
not as significant I mean uh uh uh the
the the kind of level and policy of
racism in 1963 was much greater than it
is today but that doesn't mean we should
simply say we're going to just turn
history off at night in 1964 and say
we're going to accept these as the basis
of law forevermore society's change and
laws have to change and I think that the
kind of libertarian or classical liberal
argument which is this will fight it
through the culture don't fight it
through the law makes two immense
mistakes one is that the architecture of
the law today
is the reason that a lot of this stuff
exists in the first place uh because
companies are reacting to uh what are
now kind of abusive and frivolous civil
rights cases they adopt the EI programs
as a legal defense mechanism because the
the Civil Rights apparatus has exist
today has gone a bit off track
and they're in for huge liabilities you
know for example Tesla I think faced a
judgment of more than 150 million
dollars because one contractor had a
racist comment to another contractor uh
uh uh you know in the elevator or
something uh some kind of thing is hey
look that's wrong you should get fired
maybe you support getting rid of the
Civil Rights Act because
okay but then you're just saying but
it's it's the bedrocker you know
that's where you and I differ though
Chris because uh you know when you say
this when you say the Civil Rights Act
you know there's a lot there people
think of you know the the Woolworths
counter and the segregated buses and
everything and public accommodations but
if we're talking about you know uh the
ability to you know sue a company into
the ground because some employee made a
racist comment or something like that I
am I would be in favor of you know
rolling that sort of thing back I think
that's probably excessive and so I would
support initiatives that take us in that
direction and not initiatives such as
the stop woke act that are like well
we're just going to pile more and more
categories on top of what we already
have let me finish my point though so
the first problem is that it's a kind of
blindness to the fact of where the
problem originates from you can't change
something culturally that originates in
law and then the second thing is just
from a practical standpoint you know
it's like saying you know uh we're going
to if culture and law are the two fists
uh of political change
it's like telling a boxer to go in the
ring with one hand time behind his back
I mean your your self kind of neutering
what is the point of having elections of
having legislators of having a legal
system if you're not willing to use it
to improve the law from what it is
previously or what it is currently I'm
not sure yeah but I think we disagree
that improving the law is empowering the
government to go into private businesses
and telling them what they can and
cannot do in different terms than you
know whatever overreach exists this goes
further than that going into higher
education going into uh you know
traditional Public Schools you yourself
said that your your your
um you know exposing of the way Disney
was dealing with it that they changed
their strategy that seemed like it was
effective without the law it it is that
one example is effective but for every
Disney that they rolled it back you know
uh there were you know ten others that
did nothing because these are deeply
entrenched uh uh uh economic players
that don't have to really respond to
day-to-day uh uh public incentives and
pressure but the other the other thing
is and I'm glad you mentioned it is the
public schools I think this is a good a
good section to turn to is yeah you know
again it's like saying you know would
you support a a kind of renegade School
District that says we need to teach you
know Clan ideology as the official uh
ideology of our school system uh you
know of course not you would I would
hope you would oppose that right
um thank you for extending that uh
kindness uh yeah one of you would say
hey wait a minute this is not this is
not what we want let's let's talk about
K-12 schools in a second because the
stopwoke ACT actually deals with higher
education Zach you want to run a clip um
and this you know the corporate side has
been struck down so far it'll be
appealed and that will continue to be
litigated but in Zach's uh reason uh TV
documentary on this he talked to a guy
at Florida am AMU
um a law a legal uh uh Professor law
professor uh let's run that clip and
then let's talk about how this affects
higher education and and partly in that
is whether or not is higher education
whether it's public or private is a
quantitatively different qualitatively
different than K-12 but Zach run the
clip and then let's talk some more
should not be banning ideas particularly
on college campuses when you have such a
blatant attempt to control thought and
not only control thought but had the
state control thought that's reminiscent
of societies and governments that we uh
supposedly
for Wars against Leroy Purnell a law
professor at Florida a m University or
FAMU and historically black college is a
plaintiff in the aclu's case challenging
that part of the law he's afraid that
the law will Outlaw discussions of
systemic racism which he says is part of
famu's institutional history the state
created the law school in 1949 to
accommodate two black law students who
applied to the racially segregated
University of Florida
in 1966 the state forced it to seize
admitting new students until then
Florida Governor Jeb Bush signed a law
to reopen it in 2000 Purnell worries
that if instructors were to characterize
that history as systemically racist
they'd run afoul of the Law's
restrictions around teaching the concept
I have no way of knowing that my passion
for teaching students about history
about change about the ability to bring
about change I have no way of knowing
that that isn't offensive to these
subjective judges of what is endorsing
what is not endorsing what is promoting
what is not not promoting so I do now
live with the idea that at any moment
the state can come and take negative
action against me because of my thought
I I mean
this is an incredible clip for a couple
reasons uh the first reason though uh
first and foremost is that this is a law
professor did I hear that correctly yes
yes it's a law professor who hasn't read
the bill I mean uh a law professor who's
who's who's who's I mean astonishingly
uh uh ignorant of the actual content and
the text of the law the law says very
clearly uh that you can teach about
systemic racism as a concept there's no
prohibition against that I would
challenge you to to find me the the line
or the or the section of the law that
would prohibit that uh and so I I would
say either maybe you less charitable
that this person didn't read it doesn't
understand it or maybe more charitably
trying to demagogue around it to try to
kind of create a reenactment of the uh
civil rights drama in our current time
that again as you stated doesn't apply
in the same way but you can absolutely
discuss systemic racism actually among
the divisive Concepts there's no
prohibition against discussing the idea
of of of systemic racism and there's
also a pro or also a a a a a note in the
law that says very specifically uh none
of this prohibits a discussion a kind of
neutral objective discussion uh of any
of these terms you can all talk about
them in the classroom uh and and then
accomplish then
uh Pernell uh well let me just say the
real quick because Purnell uh he's he
also authored a book uh about the
concept of color blind a colorblind
legal system and how that he believes
that's completely mistaken there is
language in here right now about how you
can't say that racial colorblindness is
racist for instance so that was one con
specific concern of his
um and so it the the idea here is you
know by uh saying these broad Concepts
and then like you can't endorse them
well you know what if that is what he
believes that promoting an idea of
racial color blindness is just a way to
paper over systemic racism in the system
and therefore you're Banning him from
really talking about systemic racism and
saying that it exists it creates a
chilling effect is his argument
and and it creates a chilling effect in
classroom discussion I mean look uh
everything creates a chilling effect a
couple things though I'd like to finish
my original point the first point is
that I think it's a misreading of the
law and and likely a deliberate kind of
demagoguery about the law but the second
Point again for Libertarians you know is
it this is a public institution this is
chartered funded by taxpayers uh it's
it's it's it's enabled into being by the
legislature and again the principled
libertarian argument is to tell the
Professor that's great all well and good
or maybe on libertarian grounds we we
oppose this specific measure but we
actually support abolishing your
institution altogether and I'd like to
get you guys I mean do you support that
would you like to just abolish no I
don't I have I have a ba two masters and
a PhD all from State universities State
supported universities uh in many cases
state-supported universities get less
money than private institutions from
public sources that's a that's a red
herring
you would have more luck telling me that
I should support the uh the abolition of
any mandatory education that I might go
with you whether it's public or private
but that's fine no that's that's not
what what's at issue here the question
is is that do you create do you create
an educational space you get into that
in a very bizarre position though right
position I don't think hold on we
support the existence of these publicly
financed publicly chartered institutions
that are that are created by
legislatures but we oppose the public
having any say in what goes on inside of
them
you you what you create and what we've
seen created and this is empirically
validated so that fiction of academic
freedom of freedom of speech a kind of
surface level uh uh allegiance to it but
you don't have any of those things in in
the large public universities no I do
because what what is the point of higher
education you're you're you're having
adults going to this institution to
either seek knowledge or skills for the
job market that should be you know these
are all consenting adults that are
involved in this the to the extent that
the government should or shouldn't be
funding it that's kind of a side issue
which we we can discuss
but that's fundamental you you say that
you're against impressed review of the
government Chris you're not you're not
libertarian do you think all all
publicly funded or publicly supported uh
education should be disbanded
no I'm not libertarian at all okay well
look there's a difference between being
libertarian Milton Friedman you know
when he was talking about school
vouchers was not saying that all
education should be privatized the state
need not necessarily provide it but if
you're funded so there is no fundamental
libertarian argument you're going to
have a state institution ultimately it
has to reflect the values and the will
of the voters of that state at a higher
Advantage
exactly if I might just ask what is what
are the values of Florida of the voters
of Florida are the is it you know is it
that we should never talk about systemic
racism or that every discussion and
every research project by every academic
should have to go through some kind of
ballot initiative process this is it it
seems ridiculous what you're proposing
Chris that you create you create
universities that allow for the
production of knowledge and the
discussion question of that and there
are going to be some limits I assume
violent overthrow of the government
causing immediate violence fighting
words but other than that I think most
people in Most states are like you know
that makes sense to let it go as far as
possible sure but the people of the
State of Florida have expressed their
will through their representatives in
the legislature through the governor's
that what Florida a m will be in line
with the values of the people of Florida
and and again I would also say even from
a broader perspective I I agree that the
purpose of the University should be the
pursuit of knowledge The Pursuit Of
Truth
um it should be done in a way that those
are the highest values of the public
university system uh I I don't uh like
you I guess I don't support abolishing
them but when they're off track when
they're not supporting those values when
they're not pursuing those as the Telos
or the highest principal of the
University it's up to the voters to
Institute reforms and what we have is a
situation where there is not uh there's
a kind of uh uh uh a a a kind of written
idea of academic freedom but the actual
on the ground facts I've talked to a lot
of professors in the UF system uh that
are conservative that say I can't
express my opinion I can't do the
research I want if I say that I'm
conservative I won't get tenure my ideas
are suppressed I'm forced to go through
these diversity trainings I'm forced to
wear BLM t-shirts I'm forced to to mimic
the the kind of ideology
forced to attend oppression exercises
that deem nobody should believe nobody
should have compelled speech nobody
should be
forcedure
has yielded this as the status quo this
is a problem for people within the the
system it's also a problem for the
public to say hey wait a minute
if you're a public if you're
professoriate if you're faculty because
of the hiring and because of the funding
and because of the selection process is
now in many public universities 20 30 40
to 1 depended on the Departments between
progressives or liberals and
conservatives you have a massive
imbalance in faculty you have an
Administration that has adopted Dei as
the highest principle of the universe
enforcing professors to to bow down to
left-wing diversity ideology they're
forcing professors to sign diversity
statements okay they're forcing
professors to be hired on the basis of
their commitment to these ideologies you
have a huge problem and yeah it is what
I'm hearing is that well you can't do
anything about it because you know
government bad who said nobody can do
anything about it but then to to say
that you cannot talk about certain
things you cannot talk about certain
Concepts
if students if students feel aggrieved
or taxpayers they can take they can have
lawsuits they can bring charges up
against people throw that up that does
not seem to me to be a particularly
workable to say that you're not being
prohibited about anything there's a
prohibited Concepts
blind acceptance of the status quo
mistaking the status quo or some kind of
Liberty and you're saying well file a
lawsuit no well so if you recognize the
basis of the the the law to regulate the
behavior of the institution but you
can't pass any new laws we have a crisis
in our universities our universities
what's the crisis is that you have
conservative state universities that
have excluded conservative academics and
administrators
the public dollar they use the public
charter they use public resources to
promote a far left-wing ideology not
just in in the classroom which again is
fine whatever not a huge problem but
more importantly through the organs of
the administrative apparatus you have
you know some universities have you know
multi-million dollar budgets from for
Dei commissars that are there to
regulate the minute behavior of students
there to have professors bow down to
diversity ideology
they believe that well you can't do
anything about it you know no no no wait
wait wait wait stop stop you're making
all kinds of Leaps and Bounds here but
first off does a stopwoke act also uh
apply to private universities
uh
correct
no it's public universities only but um
pulling funding from Dei departments is
a separate proposal that you know you
might be you know to the extent that
Federal funding is going to that you
might be able to get Libertarians on
board with something like that what
we're talking about is you're
prohibiting certain Concepts adults
teaching other adults about these
Concepts whether you agree or disagree
I'll read line 104. uh this man you know
the the previous prohibitions may not be
construed to prohibit discussion of the
concepts listed therein as part of a
course of training or instruction
provided such training instruction is
given in an objective Manner and what
does that mean that means you can't
force students to believe that they're
inherently inferior because of their
ancestry yeah but you can talk about it
as a Google Assistant
leave anything but you can endorse and
say I believe that this view of the
world is correct and I'm going to teach
a class that way that is academic
freedom that is kind of fundamental to
just a liberal Society the idea that uh
it's the it's the marketplace of ideas
and the marketplace and let's talk about
the marketplace of ideas okay
it's not a Marketplace of ideas uh when
again a Marketplace of ideas is is is is
is predicated on the idea that there are
a kind of unlimited number of potential
competitors that are operating in the
private Market they can compete against
one another for customers that can
compete against another to produce in
this case uh educational material
ideological content and so forth a
public university is a publicly financed
cartel and in the K-12 system is a
publicly financed Monopoly
let's let's go to k through 12 in a
second okay because all higher education
is elective so it's it's a separate
category but it but it is it is not in a
competitive Marketplace it's subsidized
it's it's created and subsidized
again again even in a principled
Libertarian philosophy uh a principled
Libertarian kind of a working at
classical economics would say in the
conditions of a cartel such as the
public university system in the
conditions of an economic Monopoly such
as the K-12 system
State intervention is Justified and so
the idea that the public universities
are a free Marketplace of ideas is so
contrary to the basic facts on the
ground it takes a kind of abstraction a
leap of abstraction
it takes a basic look at reality there
are over 4 000 four-year colleges and
universities in the country the vast
majority of them are and the vast
majority of students I think it's
something like 80 or 85 percent of
students go to state-supported schools
there is massive Choice there is massive
Choice it's true
Chris just let me let me finish my
comment there's no question that the the
academy is you know and particularly
Elite schools tend very hard left
um you know I'm somebody I went through
you know undergrad graduate school all I
I have as much education as you can get
I was virtually with the exception of my
ex-wife as a grad student I was the only
libertarian that I met for most of those
years I understand you know what it is
like and it has gotten worse in the past
30 years there's no question of that but
to say that there is no a possibility of
choice there is no academic freedom or
to say given the certain circumstance
now all we're going to do is empower the
state and actors of the state to change
the way things are allowed to be
discussed that doesn't seem to me to be
a very workable Solution
that's a good point but we'd like to
respond I'd like to respond so first of
all it's not the pivoting discussion
that's the kind of uh uh most
challenging portion of this uh to kind
of to to defend on a political basis but
this is really targeted at
Administration this is targeted at Dei
seminars this is targeted at uh uh uh
you know the orientation programs but
that is in the prohibited Concepts and
in the way the laws it actually it does
hit it does hit classroom discussion and
it is are not professors feel a chilling
provides it provides a special exemption
for classroom discussion that I that I
read off earlier but it's really I think
fundamentally targeted at that
administrative Behavior injecting these
Concepts forcing students to bow down to
these Concepts and using the public
funds to to promote and endorse these
Concepts as the truth but the second
problem and I think that it's an even
greater problem is as you said somewhere
between 85 and 90 percent of college
students University students attend
state-affiliated or state finance
colleges and universities and so I know
that a Libertarian if you said well 85
percent of the breakfast cereal that
Americans consume is produced by the
government you guys would go apoplectic
you guys would say we need a thousand
breakfast cereals May a thousand
breakfast cereals remove we need to
remove all regulation and financing for
the breakfast cereal cartel administered
by by the state and yet when it comes to
public universities it's like the the
kind of the principles start to
dissipate I know I I think if 90 of
students attend state universities how
is this not at minimum a cartel and at
maxicum really you said well I agree
with you I agree with you Monopoly yeah
break it I agree with you regulated I I
agree with you that it is a cartel and I
want to see the what the measures I'm
interested in are things that break down
that cartel and move you know Nick Nick
already mentioned there there's a lot of
choice out there there's conservative
leading universities I would like to see
that guy
there's a there's a wide variety among
state universities anyway I mean you
know differences there are many
departments of the government that you
can appeal to that strikes me as a weak
argument on Libertarians no no what I
agree with you that when Public Funding
is involved it does it does call for a
different type of oversight and if it's
the private business but you've already
made it clear that you don't care about
that because private corporations should
be forbidden from teaching certain types
of people I'm not a Libertarian I'm not
a Libertarian and I dial in the realm
yeah no one and what I'm saying is
we're going to get to K-12 education in
a second Zach did you want to finish
your thought
no my my only point is that uh if if it
is a cartel and I tend to agree with you
that there are cartel-like Tendencies
there that the why wouldn't the effort
be towards breaking down that cartel and
uh make making it easier for
universities to get accreditation Yes
disentangling Federal money from the
universities uh getting rid of federal
student loans all this stuff is things
that Libertarians can get behind and I
think would help with a lot of these
problems that you're talking about
because it would weaken the power of
these institutions to the degree that
the ideas are just being subsidized and
not truly triumphing in a Marketplace of
ideas I'm I'm fine with that I actually
support all of that I'm going to be I'm
working on some model legislation to
address some of those points but the
fact of the matter is that we still have
a situation in the Here and Now where
you know roughly uh nine out of ten
college students attend state government
institutions and so you have to deal
with that problem and again I think the
libertarian problem uh and and classical
liberal problem is that you want to deal
with it in abstraction well you know I'd
prefer University I'd prefer you know
that all the universities are private I
prefer you know massive regulatory
reform but but hey that's not practical
it's not going to happen in in the near
term and you're still left with the
problem that well what do you do with
the institutions that exist today you're
preferring an abstraction which is easy
to defend because it's not really in the
political role you went to you went to
Georgia institutions today be able to
everyone be treated like adults that can
discuss ideas like adults and not have
the governor of Florida saying you know
what concepts are allowed to be endorsed
in a college classroom or not that that
would be my preference that's great but
again that's not the that's not the main
focus and as I told you there's no
prohibition on discussing the concepts
I've read you the legislative language
if they're endorsed yes if they're
endorsed it is okay so let's let's hold
on let's get it let's get an example
here you think that a University of
Florida Professor should say in a
classroom I hereby endorse and and and
and and and and and and and will
implicate into you and it will require
you to believe uh that uh that uh Nordic
people are the Aryan race and are vastly
superior to the to the other races of
the globe is that happening to say so
yeah I don't know how that person gets
hired in the first place but honestly
like whatever crazy thing some Professor
is teaching it doesn't matter what I
think about it matters what yes or no
you know if the students want to take
their class so yeah he's saying yes
Chris yes okay and that's a principal
position
what happens is when you start a Nazi
style talking points in the class there
are places to teach in universities in
America it happens I I wouldn't want to
take their class but yes there are
terrible ideas that get put forward in
college classrooms I'm not going to
argue with you the whole idea
all right well I think hey I'll give you
credit for being principled you don't
want uh
let's let's shift to uh K-12 education
because this is the focus of earlier
laws that were coming out of Florida
that you were involved with Chris and
again you know you are you are on a hot
streak you know you are Neil Young like
Circa 1970 uh you know whether or not
you're going to have like the next five
years you're gonna just be pumping out
great album after great album or not
it's not clear but let's turn to K-12
education yes and some of the concerns
that are are being raised here about
limiting what is you know at what level
is public education controlled and Chris
do you want to talk about your efforts
to yes essentially have the state you
know and and when we say the state we're
talking about at the state level yes
control like ultimately what is the
domain of what is taught yeah I
I were in the abstract that each School
District set its own curriculum there's
more latitude there's more
decentralization I've I've advocated for
Universal school choice and in fact my
work on critical race Theory according
to the governor of Arizona Doug Ducey uh
was was a contributing factor for them
actually passing Universal School of
Choice in Arizona after they pass an
anti-crt Bill the year prior and so I I
think we're probably largely on an
agreement on decentralizing on creating
a a more options on universal school
choice I I I think we can say bracket
that aside but again the reality is two
things the status quo is is is really
twofold that the public education system
like the public university system is a
cartel more actually a monopoly you have
90 of this yeah
and the curriculum in the State of
Florida and in most other states is
already set at the state level and so
you're trying to say hey what do we
decide as a people that we want to
transmit the values that we want to
transmit and all concede private
corporations is a tougher argument
public universities is a tougher
argument we've had you've made some good
points uh I've tried to defend the best
I can but K through 12 argument there's
the K-12 schools I mean the the the the
the the fact is very simple the state
sets the curriculum uh it's a 90 uh
Monopoly control and then it's also
miners who are in many cases compelled
to attend no they are always compelled
to attend and I think that you should
have the widest latitude I I think you
know frankly that the state could say
um you know the the state could actually
do go much further and say this is what
we do teach this is what we don't teach
this is the behavior that we want this
is the behavior we don't want and I
actually don't think that that's even
the right I think that's a duty of
legislators
have to do that because you're so what
what are concepts of kids and you need
to make sure that those values are are
in accordance with you people in the
State uh you consider yourself I mean
you know just as a backdrop statement
it's like when you talk about you know a
state like Florida
um which has millions of people and tens
of millions of people to talk about the
values of that state that is an
abstraction I think where you're just
saying okay you know what they all
believe this one thing or this is the
Orthodoxy that we're going to impose on
everybody throughout the state but
whatever abstraction that's actually
very very personal very intimate and you
have uh you have no but you're acting as
if there is one so somebody who lives in
the Florida Panhandle and somebody who
lives in the keys they are all of the
same hive mind that is Florida and we're
going to impose an orthodox centralized
educational curriculum on them but
that's the stat status quo a and then
yeah but wait you were just saying if
public you have a you know as a
legislature you have an executive and
you have courts that can as a
conservative as a conservative
traditionally conservatives and
particularly on the school issue we're
always saying that local control is
better and they were always right that
moved things
but that isn't what you're doing here
with with your legislation centralizes
power in the State House
is already centralized there's no change
in the in how these things are okay so
now you had been you have been
haranguing us for like putting up with
the status quo but now you are saying I
want the status quo but I want to be in
the driver's seat
driver good point but but it's not it's
not right as I said
um no I actually support and all of the
above approach I think that you know I
I've advocated for Universal school
choice I would support a bill that says
we're we're spinning out curricular
control to local districts local school
boards I would support that I think that
parents should have a country should it
be to them
should it be the parent
um ultimately the parent or guardian of
the kid
who actually controls where the school
dollars go that's what's revolutionary
in Arizona yes of course I do yeah but I
also why are we why are we talking about
your efforts on that as opposed to your
efforts on saying okay these are certain
Concepts these are certain books these
are certain themes that cannot be taught
that should not be taught anywhere where
have I said that well I I I'm not saying
that there are books
uh you know I I think that certainly the
pornographic materials should not be
included and then school districts and
School classrooms and parents frankly as
a kind of veto Force as participating in
the institution should have a a sense of
curating a curriculum you you have a
limited time you choose certain books
and you don't choose others that's not
respanning a book and and the fact is is
again I think that the the the kind of
I'm not talking about that but I'm just
saying why why aren't schools I mean
isn't the easy and I think this is
something that we might agree on you
know both from a conservative and a
Libertarian point of view if you have
Universal school choice issues about
what the school curriculum disappear as
a public matter because it's schools
will put out curricula and parents will
either choose them or not
and that's exactly why I support it I've
flogged for it I've advocated for it
I've worked I I you know I think I have
some contribution certainly the the
activists on the ground in Arizona but
you know the legislators and and the
governor whom I spoke with all said hey
CRT was a huge Boon for us to get
Universal school choice after having
tried for for you know over across two
decades and so I I'm happy to take a
very limited credit because look I I
support that but even in Arizona where I
think you now have 25 000 families that
are going through the application
process to get their dollars you're
still going to have for the foreseeable
future a public school system with 70 80
percent of of of K-12 students and so
you can't simply say well we have choice
so we can abdicate responsibility and
the problem with again with the
classical liberal or libertarian view is
that uh what happens is that the the
refusal or the fear to act in the public
sphere seeds the territory to the people
on the far left who have no such can
function no such hesitation and they
will go all the way until they get
dominance over the administration
dominance over the curriculum dominance
over the ideology that's transmitted
from the state to the child and so you
have this problem that I think actually
you know spans across all three of these
domains we've talked about where
classical liberals Libertarians really
are not willing to to take uh to
dismantle left-wing civil rights uh
apparatus but they're unwilling and and
they really come out Furious about any
kind of right-wing civil rights
apparatus or civil rights such as
campaign well you know you say well I
wouldn't get rid of the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 but I don't support
strengthening it to protect people from
uh from their their their public you
should read reasons reasons voluminous
coverage on you know why uh masterpiece
cake shouldn't be forced to bake cakes
they don't want to I mean are you yeah
would you argue would you argue that
under civil rights legislation then if
you're talking about this that you know
uh Christian Bakers whatever that means
you know people who are Christians who
bake cakes should be forced under civil
rights law to bake you know gay wedding
cakes
I would not so I think we're probably in
alignment there but then if that changes
your Embrace of the Civil Rights
a small three-man bakery is not
comparable to a uh you know
multi-billion dollar publicly funded uh
kind of State uh uh State organized
public education system and so they're
categories they're categories and you
cannot compare if you want to disrupt
the left's control of uh you know the
public schools isn't the best way to do
that is to give people the right of exit
through giving them money I'm
aggravating for both yeah because I'm
pregnant because you don't get both you
don't get both because what what you're
arguing is if Ron DeSantis is in charge
of things and you agree with Ron
DeSantis you're okay
and for me what I worry about and Zach
why don't you pipe in after this but you
know what I worry about is like okay you
know I'm not I don't particularly go
along with Rhonda Sanchez on a lot of
stuff I don't want Charlie Crest I don't
want you know lot and Childs if we go
back in Florida Governor history or Jeb
Bush necessarily I want to be left to uh
you know make my own decisions where I
go where I send my kids to school how I
run my business what kind of colleges
courses can offer I agree but but that's
that that ship has sailed you know many
many decades ago again you have a public
a Government monopoly in K-12 you have a
government car test I know the way to
destroy the public Monopoly as long as
you have a government enforced HR a
government required a HR System in the
large corporations leave me alone is not
a viable is not a viable political
platform in 2020. it wasn't a viable
political platform in in in 19 in a
1995 and and so you have to deal with
the world as it is I would prefer an
abstract Utopia in which parents can can
go to can go take their kids to schools
in a way that they can take them to
restaurants there's an unlimited number
of restaurants they're all organized by
small things it's tailored to them I
would love that system okay but we do
not have that system in the next half
century
have to deal with the system as it is
today and my friends were in the
classical liberal Camp I cannot stress
enough to them that uh abdicating the
responsibility of governing public
institutions creates a vacuum and a void
in which the worst people in the country
will take Extreme Measures to control
the ideological transmission from the
state to the child from the state to the
student uh from the state to the
corporate HR office this must be
disrupted uh Florida is doing a great
job it actually disrupting it in a way
that is Meaningful not just appealing to
some few future abstract utopian Zach
talk a little bit about your school
choice situation in Florida and you you
moved from California to Florida why
don't you talk a little bit about that
and
um we've got a few more minutes
um but let's do that and then we'll come
tomorrow
and why that's why I don't understand
why you are saying it's abstract when
the momentum is has been building and
really accelerated through the pandemic
I mean you mentioned Ducey already they
have Universal vouchers now in Arizona
here in Florida we have uh we don't have
vouchers but we have uh pretty much
unlimited school choice there's like
three great schools within driving
distance of where you know five minutes
of where I am
um and it my worry when you say it
should be all of the above is that all
of the above is sort of in tension with
each other because if you're like okay
uh we need school choice but in the
meantime we need to implement these
anti-crt bills and also we're defining
CRT In This Very broad way well then
you're you're saying well we're we are
going to implement from the top down
what the proper curriculum is is going
to be
um and in the in the meantime you're
kind of dividing
um you know the school choice Coalition
because some people who like school
choice might want to send their kids to
a you know woke school and some might
want to send them to like a Hillsdale
Classical Academy or something like that
I mean and a private school is not
restricted by these private schools are
not restricted by these laws private
schools are restricted by economic
reality I mean but do you think do you
think that Charter Schools should be
restricted and and just I want to ask
you this because if we're if we do go to
a voucher type system then we are going
to be talking about State money going to
private schools do you want these kind
of strings attached to that state money
because
I support the bill in Arizona
wholeheartedly and explicitly uh forbids
uh any kind of curricular interference
uh in private institutions that receive
that that received essentially the
voucher money from parents I I think
that's right but again uh let's let's
deal with empirical reality uh Universe
Universal school choice is a reality in
Arizona
um and yet uh you know 85 or 90 of of
students K-12 students in the state of
Arizona next year will be in Public
Schools traditional public schools and
so you have to deal with that and again
in the abstract I would love that if uh
people choose to exit the the system is
reshaped that's going to take time there
is no possibility of of of kind of this
this this
private descent totally decentralized
parent driven uh uh uh uh uh uh you know
Universal School of Choice system in the
near term most people attend public
schools and again if you if you say well
I would prefer a system that doesn't
exist to A system that does exist the
the duty is on you to say well what are
we going to do in the meantime how do we
manage and how do we and how do we say
the Next Generation or two generations
of students that will pass through the
traditional K-12 system
like I'm not I'm not I'm not convinced
that your vision of you know first off
that you'll be able to implement these
things immediately and then it all
disappears I mean this is one of the
reasons why Corey DeAngelis who used to
work at reason you know highly known in
the school choice error he says that the
attempt to end
um bad curricula through top-down
approaches whether it's at the you know
federal or the state level are always
doomed to failure because the the
entrenched bureaucracies always work
around this kind of stuff the way to do
it is to change the system fun
fundamentally and he can already show
where places where this stuff has been
banned and then it comes up in different
way and they come up with different
languages
no no no it's actually been quite
effective I was worried about that but
what we've seen it's actually been very
effective so you can't simultaneously
argue that well they'll get around it
anyways so there's no point to it well
yeah no no no if you have if you have a
large plot pot of money and where the
school is controlled from the state
house or even from the school board you
have to you have to fund it from the
bottom up that's that's the solution and
you say oh we're not doing anything if
you have Universal school choice which
is already rolling out now finally covet
helped you know push that and to be
honest your exposure of different types
of like the insanity and it wasn't just
you I mean it's like as as you know
covid put what kids were learning in
people's family rooms and living rooms
they were like holy [ __ ] like I gotta do
something different yes this is moving
forward and it will be be fast it's not
doing nothing to say we want to
radically restructure the way that
school funding is done that's what
changes
I agree with that completely I I and
from a from a pragmatic perspective even
the rosiest projection from the school
choice leaders in Arizona predict maybe
a maximum uh in in say the next
generation 15 20 of students will opt
out that's in the most optimistic
projection in the Next Generation and so
in the meantime uh uh uh even if they
hit that optimistic projection which I
hope that they do uh you're you're still
dealing with the vast majority millions
of kids running through the traditional
K-12 system and I think that the
defeatist attitude of saying well
they're gonna work around it well it's
really bad Well we'd approve we'd prefer
a system that is radically different is
abdicating the responsibility that
legislators have legislators inherit a
system in which which they are the the
deciders of which values are transmitted
how education is structured what what
curriculum is is is uh is is required of
schools but see I don't think you should
I don't think it should be that way that
I think you have the defense
to the students I don't think it should
be that way I do want that future where
people are choosing to opt into the uh
systems or the uh classrooms or or the
workplaces that already reflect their
values
with the public school system that will
still have 80 or 90 you just throw up
your hands and say well forget it no you
don't throw up your hands first off
everybody changes as this stuff starts
happening but what do you mean like
because overnight you know just because
something is an edict that doesn't get
rolled out immediately everybody's
worked in companies where it takes
forever for stuff so the idea that like
you have the one switch that can change
everything overnight and anything else
is kind of [ __ ] is I think that's an
overdrawn argument I'm saying even
though on the future in the meantime the
fact that you get there even according
to the most the most optimistic
estimates you're going to have the in
effect a public school dominated system
and the question is swimming also that a
hundred percent that everybody is
captive I mean I think part of you know
part of what I I find unconvincing in
the way that you frame this is that
there is universal agreement that all
first of all schools are doing is all
CRT all the time and that's the main
concern but also that everybody agrees
with you in your conception of what is
good and proper and this other stuff is
being I mean it's so not everyone agrees
and this is empirically empirically
testable in fact approximately two by a
two to one margin the public does agree
with me including white parents black
parents Latino parents agrees with you
what that school should be better
appreciation in K-12 schools and so
nationally uh it's a two to one margin
uh that agrees with me these top these
these Concepts and the easiest way to
change that is higher and and in
conservative States it's even higher
than that and so what you're saying is
that if a overwhelming majority of
parents say hey we want we want these
values transmitted in our publicly
financed K-12 education system I think
that's a reasonable thing to say well
the the overwhelming majority of the
public uh through the through the
legislative process through their
elected representatives gets to decide
what is taught to their children what is
talking about the best way to do that is
by giving the parents the money and then
having them vote with their dollars
because all of the other stuff I agree
this is complicated it's just as it's
just as pie in the sky and all of that
and this will do that overnight and it
will leave the people left in schools
where people are leaving they'll either
adapt or they'll die but it won't do it
overnight and we we know nothing nothing
will happen overnight actually that's
that's the real truth can I just in in
the last couple of minutes that we have
um Zach would you and we'll give Chris
the last word on this but could you kind
of summarize both in your video about
um you know the softball act as well as
an earlier one about restrictions put on
um you know education in K-12 schools in
Florida where your kids attend what is
you know what's your sense of what what
are your reservations about the way
Chris is talking about things and what
do you think is the best way forward
sure sure
um and real quick I just want to bring
up this one comment and I saw uh someone
pointed out no it is not State money
Zach when I uh said that the vouchers
were uh going to have strings attached
to him and I uh agree with that uh this
is just refunding money to the parents
and so hopefully there would be no
springs attached but I my my point is
just that you know whenever these
um kinds of things are enacted the
government tries to attach conditions to
money uh and I that that kind of gets
into the answer to my question is that I
want to escape that that's what I want
to see
um I'm I'm grateful that Florida is a
pretty good choice State and that I was
able to find a school that I'm really
happy with for my kids I want that for
everyone
um across the country I you know in in
terms of the laws that have been imposed
on uh K-12 schools I think a lot of it
has been kind of overblown
um in Florida you know there was
um basically saying don't teach about uh
you know gender sexuality and uh K
through three uh or you know uh and then
um age appropriate at the older levels I
think
I will concede to Chris like yeah
something has to there has to be some
standards if you're going to have a
public system
um I think there might now be a little
bit of an overreaction happening where
people are just like freaking out about
the the very idea of sex ed being taught
and any sort of like LGBT aspect of sex
ed being integrated into the curriculum
I think all that is part of uh you know
evolving social progress and that's what
I worry about with this attitude of we
need to have our state leaders
transmitting the values uh as if we're
just like radio responders and they're
the antenna you know sending it out I I
think that's just the the wrong way to
think about it the wrong way to think
about how social progress happens I I
don't have all the answers as to you
know what aspects of CRT which has
become this this extremely broad
category are bad and and what are good I
mean the that it's a mixed bag and that
all has to be worked out and it's only
going to be worked out if we're allowed
to discuss it freely and honestly and so
I'm supportive of ideas uh of both you
know cultural projects like Chris's that
that expose
um kind of insanity but um also yes
legislative and government action that
enables a more vibrant
um competitive ecosystem at all levels
of Education from kindergarten all the
way through higher education and uh so I
hope that the focus can be more uh you
know laser focused on that going forward
and also I'll add Zach based on
conversations we had also the
transparency elements in some of the
DeSantis or or the Florida legislation
is really important uh Chris I think we
all agree the idea that schools are not
being transparent with parents yeah is
[ __ ] mind-blowing you know the idea
that schools would arrogate to
themselves what information they share
with parents
um you know is it is just wrong but
Chris uh especially pressing in a if it
is a government-run school yes they
should have very strict transparency
guidelines I agree with that and it's
not even a question I've developed a
model bill on transparency for K-12 uh I
I believe versions of it were introduced
in maybe 20 State legislatures none of
them passed in full I think that's
something that we can certainly revisit
I I guess kind of the closing thought is
that there's points that we have
agreement on I think to the ultimate
Point uh uh is that there should be
transparency in a public system I think
the ultimate point is that in a system
that is dominated by the government as a
cartel or a monopoly more Choice more
opt-out more decentralized control is
good I think we agree that ultimately it
would be nice to have local school
districts that are most responsive to
local communities in control of the
curriculum uh and I think that all of
those points are are are hugely
important long-term goals I think where
we disagree and disagree quite strongly
is in the interim period where you
actually have to fight these fights and
my argument is is in essence an argument
that is uh Democratic an argument that I
think it actually contests uh the
unaccountable state bureaucracy it's
fundamentally a liberatory or kind of
libertarian in in in an old sense of the
word that parents when you get parents
that show up at the school district
saying I don't want my kid taught that
he's racist because of his skin color I
don't want my kid thought uh that that
you know there are that that he might be
a pansexual genderqueer uh you know uh
uh uh and has his name changed and his
pronouns changed without notifying me
um this is inappropriate for the state
to be manipulating my students my
child's sexuality it's inappropriate for
the state to be transmitting a
inherently racist ideology as gospel
truth and my kind of realist
preoccupation is to say we have to deal
with the system as it is in the interim
which will be a generational project and
that that voters have the right to
restrict the state from uh abusing and
manipulating their children and other
people's children and working with the
system as it is actually requires us as
responsible adults to empower the people
who are showing up at school board
meetings empower the 70 of parents who
don't want gender ideology in K through
five empower the parents and the voters
who don't want CRT by large margins in
some cases by 40 Point margins to deny
them the ability to shape and reform
public institutions is actually deeply
anti-democratic it's anti-liberation
it's anti-individual it's anti-culture
and so we should link arms together in
that long-term vision of
decentralization and choice and
flexibility and freedom uh while I would
say to my friends in the classical
liberal and libertarian spaces
by working against what we're doing in
the interim is actually working against
those very fundamental structures of the
Republic and those very fundamental
values that we share in common all right
well thank you uh you know there's a
broad disagreement in that because I
think what we're saying is you can cut
to the chase immediately and also that
doesn't explain why giving the
government more control over speech that
takes place in corporate boardrooms and
things like that achieves that goal but
I appreciate you for coming on and
talking as candidly and it's worth
rightly I suspect we'll be uh doing this
more thank you Chris Ruffo for talking
to reason during this live stream Zach
Weissmuller always good to see you and
uh I'm happy if somebody has to live in
Florida it's not me and that is going to
say well there it's great fun I I
appreciate the spirited uh debate and
conversation I appreciate it wonderful
stuff thanks
bye-bye